quoi dans la matrice
bienvenue dans le space jam wow ce monde
est énorme
j'ai besoin de rassembler une équipe d'élite suivez-
moi doc je suis une photo de groupe de dessin animé
parlant d'expérience qui va
laisser une marque
[Musique]
j'ai hâte de voir quoi  je
deviens ici je suis flippant robin nerd alert space
jam ready pg 16 juillet. bienvenue dans le
space jam
tu dois te moquer de moi le 16 juillet
un seul jeu compte
pg 16 juillet. préparez-vous quoi dans la
matrice
[Musique]
vous devez gagner ce jeu et obtenir notre signe de
retour
bugs rassembler
la ligne pour la salle de bain va être
fou
si vous perdez tous les morceaux seront
supprimés pour toujours
[Applaudissements]
espace  confiture sur nouvel héritage prêt pg
vous